transparency and authorization
mechanisms for experts that was
announced earlier this week
we have the pleasure to have here with
us today evp domskins
and commissioner kiriakides this
press conference will be followed by a
technical briefing so the press
conference
will be short and we will be able to
provide you
more details during the technical
briefing so please i give the whole
floor first to the evp
uh good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
uh today
the commission has adopted an
implementing regulation
uh making the export of certain products
subject to an
export authorization regulation concerns
transparency and export of code 19
vaccines
the protection and safety of our
citizens is a priority
and the challenges we now face left us
with no
other choice but to act vaccines are key
to the recovery
and to bringing the pandemic under
control
and delivering these vaccines to our
citizens
is the most critical task right now
this is a race against the clock we
cannot lose time
because of vaccines not being delivered
on agreed schedule
to achieve this we need to ensure that
all advanced purchase agreements
for vaccines made by the european union
and are honored
we paid these companies to increase
production and now we expect them
to deliver today's measure has been
adopted with the utmost urgency
the aim is to provide us immediately
with full transparency transparency that
until now has been lacking and what
europeans
expect and if needed it also will
provide
us with a tool to ensure vaccine
deliveries
the commission has adopted a strictly
targeted measure that will allow us to
gather accurate information about the
production of vaccines
and where manufacturers intend to ship
them
the measure is time limited and
specifically applies
to those code 19 vaccines that were
agreed by advanced purchase
agreements the measure is intended to
run
until the end of march we have been very
mindful of
fully honoring our humanitarian
commitments and ensuring
to supply to many countries around the
globe that depends on the
european union these countries will be
exempted
we will keep our pledges the countries
include
our neighborhood and those low
and low middle-income countries covered
by the cox 19
facility we had to design this mechanism
to bring transparency
but also to avoid fragmentation within
our internal market
we need to be efficient and ensure
vaccines reach people across the eu
this means we need to act together and
in a coordinated way
the commission will be fully involved
along with our member states
in line with international trade rules
we will notify the world trade
organization
of this measure and now i will pass
floor to commissioner
kira kiddish to further explain the
rationale behind this measure please
thank you very much and good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen
well as you know we have been working
for the most the best parts of the past
year to
to support vaccine producers in
developing vaccines
to invest eu money for them to expand
production capacity
and to ensure the supply of vaccines for
the eu
and beyond our goal has always been
singular to bring
safe and effective vaccines to citizens
as soon as possible
for this reason we signed advanced
purchase agreements
and provided pre-financing so that
companies build the necessary
manufacturing capacity
to produce vaccines so deliveries could
start
as soon as they are authorized we do not
want and we did not want to waste a
single day
the eu together with its member states
has been consistently there to support
companies regulators and distribution
we mobilized as you have often heard us
say over 2.9 billion from our emergency
support
instrument for this purpose by investing
in science and
investing in industry we did manage to
find solutions
as challenges appeared and we want to
continue to do so
but this approach is built on trust
transparency and responsibility
commitment needs to be kept and
contracts are binding
advanced purchase agreements need to be
respected
today we have developed a system that
will allow us to know
whether vaccines are being exported from
the eu
this increased transparency will also
come with the responsibility for the eu
to authorize
with our member states these vaccine
exports
and we do this for three reasons firstly
to ensure that we can continue to work
on the basis of
evidence and complete information
secondly
to reinforce our capacity to deliver on
the advanced purchase agreements
so that citizens from the eu and beyond
can access vaccines and finally
to protect the integrity of our
substantial invest investments from the
eu
budget this is an insurance policy
in this endeavor our commitment to
global responsibility
is unwavering we will continue to
support
access to safe and effective vaccines
for all of our neighbors
and low and middle income countries
through kovacs
because this priority continues to be as
high as
as it has been from day one humanitarian
shipments and kovacs donations will not
be affected
nor will it affect our neighbors i also
want to be clear
about the fact that we commission member
states
and companies have done an exceptional
effort to develop
secure and distribute vaccines this
effort
will continue and must continue on all
sides and it depends on all parties
living to their contractual social and
moral
responsibilities today we take a step
in ensuring that accountability
continues to be
one of the key principles of our
commitment to citizens
thank you thank you evp and commissioner
we will take a few questions let me
start by jacob jacob you have the floor
hello uh yes i wanted to ask um
how uh this will work if there's a
disagreement between member states and
the commission
let's imagine a member state wants to
not
grant an authorization for an export and
the commission
wants to grant it who will have the last
word
and uh just to double check i think uh
you already said this but when this
enters into force so
this already passed the safeguards
committee thanks
yeah so on the first question how
this export authorization system will
work so it's for a member states
to prepare the decision on granting the
export authorization
and a commission is issuing an
opinion but it's unbinding opinion so to
quote from the
regulation the member states shall
decide on the request for authorization
in accordance with the commission's
opinion
well on the entry into force of the
regulation uh it's uh day following the
publication
in official journal stella i wanted to
add something
no i just want to say that this
this authorization mechanism is being
put into place to ensure transparency
which will be both in the benefit of
course
the member states uh because we are all
working in the same direction so
um i'm we're very confident that we will
have an agreement with the member states
on this because we're all working and
have been working together
in the same direction to ensure that we
have access to vaccines for all european
citizens and beyond
thank you thank you the next question
is for philip philippe you have the
floor
thank you uh phillip blankenship of
reuters you spelt out very clearly
um the exceptions in the words
humanitarian purposes and and the
kovacs recipients who obviously won't be
subject to this export control
but could you just give us what very
clearly what what are the conditions
under which
a an export authorization may be
rejected i mean
is it basically that the eu will look
uh to see that its um requirements be
met
and and subject to those being met then
accept
or reject the uh the the authorization
process
and and finally you said i mean it's
obviously factually correct that that
uh it will end to force the day after it
is published in the official journal and
i appreciate there's a process involved
here
but maybe you can kind of give an
indication of when it's likely to affect
to take effect i mean we're talking
about next week perhaps
as we have said uh from the beginning
and as i have
said and we have said from the beginning
that we are this
is in order to really protect the
advanced purchase agreements that we
have already signed
and which uh safeguard that we have the
availability of the vaccines that are
contained in this advanced purchase
agreement
so this would be the the main criteria
when we're
assessing the authorization mechanism
thank you
okay next one is alain allen please
[Music]
um
well uh as regards a list of exemptions
um there is a actually uh quite a
long list of exemptions of uh countries
um it also
includes after countries including
switzerland which
is specifically uh the question it
includes
countries in our neighborhood both
eastern
and southern neighborhood it includes
western balkans
and it includes countries
developing countries called by a corex
facility
if i'm not mistaken it's
some 92 countries
or or so so it's a long list of
countries which is
exempted well the measure is not
targeting any specific
country it's an export transparency and
authorization
measure to all certain countries which
are not
exempted
thank you for those questions i'll ask
just take
the first one first of all i want to say
something which i think is very
we have to be very clear and we have
said it many times before
uh we are not protecting ourselves
against any specific country and we're
not
in competition or in a race against any
country the only race we're in is
against this virus
and this is what is what has been in the
center of every single
uh piece of work that we've been doing
for now almost
uh it's almost a year so um
what we're doing through this mechanism
is protecting our apas
and through this uh assuring ensuring by
access of vaccines to the european
citizens and of course
beyond to our partners in kovacs to
the lower middle income countries to our
neighborhood countries thank you
thank you and we will now take a last
question
julian please go ahead
[Music]
uh well uh i can imagine that a
commissioner will have
more detailed answers specifically on
vaccines but i wanted to outline one
provision from the regulation
which foresees that companies
applying for export authorization
will also how to provide information
on their exports and export destinations
quantities and so on
uh for the period covering three months
prior to entering into force of
this regulation so i think this will
also
help to shed a full light on
export tendencies in recent weeks and
months
thank you for the question uh we can't
go into those kind of details at the
moment
customs authorities have all of all the
necessary data
um what we want to ensure is that we
have this information this level of
transparency
uh from now on and in the future i think
that this is important
i cannot stress stop stressing
the fact that the commission has
invested in large large amounts in the
development and in the production of
vaccine developers in the eu and this
was meant to ensure quick delivery upon
authorization
to citizens uh for the eu citizens and
for countries beyond of course
so it is important that we are able to
monitor this situation that we're
able to know that the commitments that
were in the epas are respected
because we are all uh in this together
in order to overcome this pandemic and
this is the reason why we're putting
this mechanism into effect now thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
for the evp and the commission for your
availability and for the journalists
that connected we will now have a
technical briefing so we will continue
discussing
this of the record thank you
[Music]
you